I'm Claire requests and I named my talk
signing being materializing the sign
because my work you know I'm really a
pre old-fashioned artist and I use
materials to propose things on a
symbolic level so let's see where this
start okay I'm starting with this image
I made with the ancient technology of
drawing it was a pencil and what you see
here is the visage of Franz Kafka who
I'm sure you all know and in the
foreground is red Peter which is a
character in his story a report to an
Academy read Peter is an eight who
became a human he's still in eighth but
he can talk and consort with humans and
I think I wanted to start with this
because I come to you as red Peter to
remind you of our animal origins and he
this one of these quotes in the story is
everyone who walks this earth feels a
tickling at his heels so you know he
doesn't really explain what that is what
is that tickling at our heels it's the
earth art itself maybe from which we
come our it is our animal ancestors or
perhaps it is death here's a scan of a
sketch I made in a little sketchbook
this is a portrait of my brother my dear
brother mark on his deathbed and for me
this is the tickling death this is this
is what it is to be material is that we
are transient and and it's such a simple
sketch but to me it trends it transmits
this idea of like the life gone out and
if you've ever been with someone who
died you know that image of when the
life desert the material is so amazing
and then what happens to the remains
well we've talked a lot about bacteria
and the microbes of course take care of
the dead and feed life new life with it
recycle the nutrients and you know if it
weren't for the microbial life we would
be a 10-story high in bed things right
but instead we're used to feed new life
and this is a picture I took in my
microscope and where that happens
usually is in the soil I'm really
interested in soil and study soil
biology because there's an amazing
cosmos under our feet what is soil it is
sand silt and clay which just refers to
particle size inhabited by all kinds of
life interdependent life cycles
you have amoeba you have protozoa you
have fungus and flagellates and
nematodes and here it is this a good
stuff mycorrhizal hyphae fungus that
communicates between plants and brings
water nutrients at the plants bidding
basically the plant controls how how
much it is nurtured and this one see
it's moving this kind of microscopy your
sample your soil sample is actually
still alive for a little while while
you're looking at it and so actually
this would all be moving I mean I had a
video but for times sake I didn't and
see these clumps these amber clumps this
is a bacteria that glues itself to each
other and so they make these micro
aggregates and this in fact produces
good soil structure because you need a
air oxygen and water to circulate in the
soil and I used to think it was just the
particle size but actually the bank the
biology makes the good structure
which i think is cool and also by the
way the bodies of the bacteria is the
best place to store your nitrogen it
won't leach out like synthetic nitrogen
okay so we've been talking a lot about
bacteria I got really interested in you
know this kind of latest wave of
medicine is especially treating the
autoimmune disorders that are prevalent
and growing in affluent countries
they're not appearing in less developed
countries so we see these this kind of
press over the last three years microbes
the trillions of creatures governing
your health germs our us some of my best
friends are germs you know it's like a
big reversal of all the ante all the
microbes idols soaps and pillows etc and
this is a shot I like with the kid in
the dirt right because there is a
continuum between the good stuff the
good microbial life in soil and that and
in our bodies right and what they have
learned is that the bacteria in your
body actually teaches your immune system
to regulate itself in the developing
child so it's very important that
children be exposed to a lot of
different kinds of bacteria so I wanted
to make this point so I made an
installation called old friends and
unloved others and it's like an
apothecary or a pharmacy where I
collected all these kind of jars and
vessels and inside the vessels are dirt
its soil and as you can see they're
little labels because all the soil comes
from very particular places because soil
is local I mean the soil in your yard is
going to be different from the soil in
my yard
because soil has history and that really
fascinates me and you can kind of
inoculate your soil with a better soil
and
in the middle of this table here in the
dark panel is a worm bin because people
that go to openings really like to be
near worms but they don't like to touch
them but I have found they really like
to be near worms and it's a yeah it's
composting and here you could like lift
the bell jar and take in the aroma
because different soils have distinct
aroma it's part of their distinction and
then these images back here kind of
blurry our soil chromatography where you
imbue the filter paper with a sodium
NOAA silver nitrate solution and then
with up you know a soil sample and it
makes a different pattern every soil
makes a different pattern it's really
it's really marvelous and that's me on
the floor while I'm doing this
installation because this week this was
in London at Whitechapel and I had the
most ungodly pain in my lower back I'd
never had back problems went to the
doctor went to the chiropractor they all
said most common complaint in America
you have a slip disc expressing the
nerve it's going to work itself out but
the chiropractor gave me exercises and
the doctor gave me drugs and there I am
doing my exercises but by the end of the
week I was really crippled I was in a
wheelchair and what I found the third
time I went to a hospital somebody to
the blood test in my immune system was
going crazy and I had a staph infection
in my spine where did I get that at the
hospital that's usually where people get
these I had been treated for something
else for cancer and so you can see that
between four and five that white area
now why am i including this because you
know I'm getting all cozy with the
bacteria right and I'm emphasizing all
this friendly bacteria and how important
it is and I left you think that I think
it's all friendly out there and this was
a great cosmic kind of kicking ass you
know that like I'm making this
installation and I almost died right
from from a very common bacteria that's
on our skin but if you're moon
bound and it gets in the wrong place
you're in trouble
okay so I've missed that show because I
was in the hospital and so I did it
again in Chicago with Chicago soil and
there since I was in residence people
could bring their sewer samples and we
look to see what kind of biology they
had okay here's another kind of
miniature life these are micro fossils
and this is what this is actually these
are the bodies that are compressed to
make petroleum so this is also is kind
of inside us which I'll talk about in a
minute and this is the way we practice
agriculture it's very fossil fuel
intensive the artificial fertilizer we
need fossil fuels to make it the
pesticides the herbicides the
mechanization etc and we actually spend
about 10 calories of fossil fuel to make
one calorie of food energy with beef
it's 55 calories more or less - a fossil
fuel energy to make one calorie of food
energy this is a mixture Henner
photograph aerial photographs and those
are feed Lots and this is the waste this
beautiful colorful in fluorescence over
here it's a really perverse way to grow
food right and this is just one one more
of the externalities is the this is the
intensification of synthetic nitrogen
which of course leeches out of the soil
and creates a hypoxic dead zone in the
Gulf of Mexico it's one of the major
problems of our countryside pollution is
excess nitrogen what was I going to do
next oh yeah ok so if you but you can
grow things otherwise without fossil
fuels by nurturing the right bacteria
and fungus in your soil and the best way
to do that is compost which is just
diverting the waste stream of org
matter and practicing an oxygenated
decomposition it has to be oxygenated
there is a kind of science to it so I
had a warm bed made a very large worm
bed in my basement and I put in it a
five foot oh that's me
five foot by nine foot American flag and
composted it and this is my proposal for
a new American agriculture that would be
practiced in collaboration with little
things worms and bacteria and fungus and
these are my externalities great soil
from my garden so I want to elevate
people's understanding of soil so I did
a big project in Germany for the last
document to actually um sorry Isis um so
I proposed soil as a basis for an
economy like as like you know like gold
or Petro dollars I'm proposing soil so I
wanted to actually materialize this
abstracting money so I made those coin
forms with a very ancient form for money
and and then I met Inga but we're used
to see in gold and I displayed it on a
gilded panel of glass so do you see the
gold and you see the ingot form but
they're reversed right now really the
reason I wanted to propose an economy on
sale is because I'm interested in this
social relations because an economy is a
social relation right and and soil is to
serve the practice it's a social
practice to to maintain the soil we
practice agriculture as an extractive
industry we just take out pick out pick
out and soil needs to be nurtured it
needs to be replenished and
we're losing soil soil is an endangered
common good
and then of course I want to make some
money notes from currency and so I made
these drawings and since we put our
important people on the money I put like
people had really contributed to organic
understanding of Agriculture much more
ecological interesting this is a J Ervin
Rodale who was a pioneer in the US and
then the money
the drawings spent some time in the soil
because I liked that materiality and I
made about forty three of these with
different figures there's Rachel Carson
down there lady Eve Balfour Sir Albert
Howard Laura Koontz Tara
and then I started to add people who had
kind of shifted our understanding of the
human as one only one actor in the great
bio system that is the planet so of
course Darwin appears in Kafka and
here's Donna Haraway with her dog
cayenne and there's a Lynn morghulis one
of my heroes and then I started putting
the creatures in the creatures that are
part of the soil food web and here is
the installation and you see out there
that green column well I worked with
this designer Ben fort on to make it
really simple really inexpensive
vertical growing systems this is a
prototype in that six weeks later all
food because Here I am saying well we
were going to make a money system out of
something that anyone can make soil but
what if you don't have land has been
there's real estate right so I wanted to
include these and there's there some of
ours we got a grant and put several of
these all around the city castle okay
back to petroleum I'm almost done The
[ __ ] went Grimke people of first nations
of ten
they're the cognitive says the Cariboo
people and they say we are caribou we
are the caribou
so this is how people identify
themselves and you'll find that in a lot
of indigenous cultures is feeling what I
am the mountain I am the river and then
um my friend and I were asking what are
we well we are petroleum this is
petroleum and petroleum also is a set of
social relations excuse me that we're
all part of so I wanted to express this
and I also you know I find it just
heartbreaking that we're in the sixth
great extinction that we know of in the
history of the world and we are the
cause of it
because I think of all that biodiversity
that took millions of years to develop
and we're just squandering it and it's
so beautiful I mean it's it's really
what I get up for is this variation of
life on Earth and so I made a library of
tears and of course I can't point the
finger at anyone else right I am part of
petroleum too and so I made these I
worked at the glassblower to make these
vessels these tear shape vessels and
inside them are products and byproducts
of petroleum refining processing so we
have like all kinds of things like
sulfur the yellow one on the edge here
this is some water that's from the
Athabascan River and mud from the
Athabascan River up in the tar sands
region of Canada I have tar sands I have
sweet crude and then I also took plants
and here's a guide a key this is like 29
feet about like 50 vessels and sembra
hand made of different materials and
some refer to the plants and animals the
life that we're trading for our appetite
for cheap energy and then I had my I
commissioned my niece who's an artist
Alex Pentecost Ferren to make a wall
paper for me
and it's very saying because I didn't
want to distract too much but it had
some of these like microfossils and it
also has this figure from Pompeii this
reading figure of mine and ER in the
house of my neighbor and so that was the
key and that's it that's what I got
[Applause]